the phrase that i use is a metaphor it's
a figure of speech in fact
john mcdonnell used the same phrase to
gordon brown in 2007
and i think as you know some of your
former colleagues on the sun i think you
worked on the sun with kevin schofield
have pointed out
that this is a figure of speech and it's
this has been used to deflect from the
real issue
and the real issue here is that the
extraordinary
has become the new normal in the labour
party and it's not normal
it is not normal what we are seeing
where you have a labour mp
well respected on both sides of the
house like frankfield for example
resigning the whip because of the
culture in the party and because of
anti-semitism it's not normal
to have two jewish labour mps give
impassioned
moving speeches in the house of commons
outlining in detail
the racism to which they have been
subject including by supporters and
members
of the labour party it is not normal for
iranian state tv to live stream and
broadcast a labour party meeting at
which an
excellent local mp like joan ryan has a
motion passed against her
and let's not forget all of the members
of parliament that i'm talking about
were democratically elected by their
constituents just a year ago
and it would appear now that people are
seeking to help them from office
now my my biggest gripe about all of
this in many respects is
distracting from the big issue for me
which is brexit we're facing the biggest
issue
since the second world war in this
country which is going to do
disproportionate damage and already is
doing disproportionate damage to lower
middle income families in this country
who are represented by the labor party
all of this
distracts from us being able to properly
do our job
on brexit we'll talk about brexit later
in the interview but i'm keen just to
focus for a little bit
on the labour party in issues within the
labour party you were talking there
about
jewish mps do you think that the labour
party
is effectively institutionally racist
yes i do if you look at the
definition of institutional racism as
outlined by sir william mcpherson in the
mcpherson report
and the mcpherson inquiry produced the
institutional racism definition
the labour party is beyond doubt for me
that is
it it's very painful for me to say that
part of the reason that i joined the
labour party my party my family started
supporting the party
um was because it was an anti-racist
party
and i think the failure to deal with the
racism that is anti-semitism
is particular and clearly is a problem
and like i mean
you know it's a sadness to listen to you
talk about what has happened and
transpired over the summer
because we failed to deal with this
issue properly most recently
um whether or not we adopt the
international holocaust memorial
alliance's definition
of anti-semitism which we should have
done right at the beginning of the
summer
if had we done that we could have talked
about the big issues
where we had new information being
exposed around climate change around
social care
around the fact that we're still seeing
wages stagnate after the global
financial growth
those are the kinds of issues in
addition of course to brexit that we
should have been talking about in the
summer would say that they have now
adopted that definition in labour's just
been talking saying that they are
going through any complaints about it
you put to him the point that this has
taken months and months and months and
months and they're still outstanding
complaints
there have been reports um you know this
week
that there have been threats of violence
against members of parliament which the
labour party has known of but has not
told members of parliament which is
which is extraordinary so the whole way
that this issue
is being dealt with has been clearly
deficient
and the leadership have acknowledged
that to be the case
and like as you said you're still
talking about it right now i've got to
ask you
if you think labour is institutionally
racist
why are you still in the party because i
want it to change
and look there's institutional racism in
many institutions in our country
and if you simply leave the field as it
were
instead of try and argue and see change
through in an organization
but i'm not sure you necessarily always
make progress and that's
that's the reason why um it's a question
we normally ask people on social media
you've got any questions for your guests
and that was a question that came up
again
and again to ask you why it is that you
are still in the party here's gareth
phillips for example
why won't you quick set the labour party
as he knew it was finished
he and those like him have a
responsibility now to form a new party
so can you categorically rule out
leaving the labour party i don't want to
leave the labour party you rule it out
though
well who knows what i'll be doing when
i'm 80. look i've been a member of the
labour party for more than 20 years
and i joined with the intention of never
leaving it i wanted to be a member of
the labour party on my
deathbed and i hope that that is the
case but ultimately this issue what i'd
say to people and lots of people ask me
this all over the country i was in
birmingham this week and
it came up actually just randomly as you
do when you're going around
and lots of people ask this question but
really i'm not the person to ask this
question of
the point of my speech yesterday was to
say actually ultimately
the job of leadership of the leadership
of the labour party
is to keep the party united and together
and to illustrate not just by what they
say but what they do
that they see the center-left social
democratic tradition in the
labour party as legitimate and by the
actions
both of supporters and members of
different traditions in the labour party
we see that they don't think the
tradition
that i belong to social democracy
center-left
labour values doesn't belong in the
party so it's for them to show
that it does untold numbers of people
have said that they don't feel welcome
in my tradition we've been clear about
how we feel
what are they actually going to do so
this issue of division splits etc it's
not an issue for me
that's the job of leaders to keep a
party together now i want to talk to you
about uh brexit
and this week we'll have a watch at the
film later on in the show um i went to
ghoul a place where
people voted very heavily to leave the
eu
and your campaign for people's vote or a
second referendum on the final deal
however you wish to
phrase it is going down shall we say
pretty badly
in places like one woman for example
saying to me that people like you think
that
she's thick that she needs to think
again and she said to me well i've
already done my thinking and
she's got a point hasn't she no look
it's nothing to do with whether i think
any
what i think of anybody's intelligence
that's a complete irrelevance to me
what matters here is the national
interest and the material circumstances
of the lady that you're
talking about i think what we do know
our country is still divided on this
as you have no doubt discovered and
we'll see in your package later
but i do think there is a shift i'm not
going to pretend that it's a huge shift
but i think there is a shift
certainly increasingly we see polls
illustrating that people want
a say on the final brexit deal that's
very clear now what they do after that
is perhaps a bit more questionable but
the point is i suppose however you voted
in 2016
nobody voted for this chaos and mess and
there are many things we now know that
we didn't know then that we
for example will have to pay a 40
billion pound divorce bill
uh for example that there isn't going to
be that 350 million pounds extra per
week going to the nhs
and in fact what we've got is eu doctors
and nurses eu citizen
doctors and nurses leaving the nhs in
droves when we've got over 100 000
vacancies
which need to be filled and we also see
businesses panasonic's a good example is
moving its headquarters
away from the uk beginning to move their
operations
to the continent now that's before we
have even left
and i think also wherever you are on the
argument
the idea that we leave and go to this
unknown world
you know a kind of blindfolded brexit
where we kind of leave but we don't know
where we're going to
troubles people um massively so i think
that's
where people are there is this real
sense
okay and maybe i voted for this but my
gosh i didn't vote for this mess
are you not playing a pretty high stakes
game here by not
backing the chequers deal that's on the
table because by not backing the
chequers deal you're effectively
maybe making the uh chances of no brexit
more likely but you're also making the
chances of no
deal more likely i mean we've seen boris
johnson for example
in the newspapers today with some pretty
choice words for that checkers deal in
for theresa may you're effectively
siding with him well boris johnson is a
disgrace there's this myth that's been
peddled
in relation to brexit that somehow it's
a fight for the people against the elite
but let's be absolutely clear
brexit is a project of the elite for the
elite i mean
boris johnson who argued for this
proposition
has walked off the field of delivery of
what he promised
has gone into his 250 000 pound a year
job
at the telegraph you've got nigel lawson
another big proponent of it
wanting to go and get residency in
france you've got jacob rees-mogg's
investment firm setting up a fund
on the continent because of the fallout
from brexit so
those guys will be all right but the
bank of england figures are telling us
that
on average people are already 900 pounds
a year
worse off as a result of this project so
let's be clear
this is a project of the elites and for
the elites
and the problem that we've got in the
house of commons is there's no consensus
i think definitely there is no majority
for us to leave without a deal
and i don't think there is a majority
for a kind of hard extreme brexit
but there is no consensus on what the
alternative should be and this is the
problem because i
if you cannot i had this exchange with
the brexit secretary dominic rob in the
house of commons this week because i
said look
if that's the case how else are you
going to resolve the impasse that we
know is coming in westminster on this
issue
if not by referring it back to the
people so they ultimately are the ones
in control of their destiny